[Musik]
wie sieht die nützlichen tipps vermochte
jetzt doch nicht nur die stellen von
bestens harmoniert sei doch absurd
[Musik]
die geschichte wird wechseln oder realer
problemstellung
das ist ganz klar dass man weiterhin
staatlich kommen sie kredite gehen
viele parlamentarier zu verkraften bei
der reaktion liebe dann schafft es ist
ihr schwierigstes jahr
der svp bringt das grenze liegt sie
müssen die initiative gegen
masseneinwanderung umsätzen mehr als
beschäftigt meine ich gar nicht weiß
dass es liegt oder sind beachtlich und
welche rolle spielen sie dann spielt
gestoppt
es ist viertel vor acht an diesem kalten
morgen
svp-mann andreas glarner trifft zuerst
ein heute geht's los
nationalrat klarer sitzt in der
staatspolitischen kommission diese
kommission muss den volkswillen umsetzen
will sich als zweiter erscheint kurt
fluri von der fdp eine halbe stunde noch
bis zur sitzung darauf ich habe mir mehr
schlaf braucht jetzt mit frau politik
immer nur eine teilnahme machen
15 15 die sieben schon alles vorbereitet
und macht es wirklich spaß das rauchen
im bett lag dass sie später als letzte
erscheint cedric wirth von der sp
oder über 3000 zumindest über die
vorschläge braucht die kommission ist
[Musik]
kommissions- immer drei ein halbes jahr
lang werden die politiker hier immer
wieder tagen
wir bleiben draußen vor der tür die
verhandlungen sind geheim
die politiker müssen die
masseneinwanderung initiative umsetzen
dafür müssen sie das gesetz ändern eine
knacknuss eine hauchdünne mehrheit der
stimmbürger wollte höchstzahlen und
kontingente für zuwanderer bei früheren
abstimmungen aber hatten sich die
stimmbürger immer klar für die
personenfreizügigkeit ausgesprochen dass
eine widerspricht dem anderen
die ersten drei stunden sind vorbei
kurze pause
außer mir die zähne ausgeschlagen
es ist nicht ganz einfach einen blick
vom verhandlungsraum zu erhaschen
aufnahmen brauchen die ausdrückliche
erlaubnis von kommissionspräsident heinz
brand svp
in der kommission sitzen 25 mitglieder
die mehrheit stellt die svp als grösste
partei mit neun personen ihr
gruppenführer gregor rutz der politische
gegner hegt einen verdacht
sein grauer wo solche zehn treffern für
den meister fünf jahren trainer dass er
wohl größten zum schluss weiter das
bürokratiemonster gemerkt dass mir die
augen der diskussion
fischer setzte sich das geländer
unakademisch das ist unser problem immer
direkt zu schlafen und abschaffung oder
standort promotion steuervorteil
bestätigt sind wie immer wieder reinigen
[Musik]
marschierte vor eurer mitspieler
franzose misato waren vier portionen mit
[Musik]
betroffenen hilft legen los
hier speist die classe politique im
galeriesaal eine stunde mittagspause
wie aber erfahren wir von den strategien
der parlamentarier
es gibt einen weg die spd spricht ihre
verhandlungstaktik beim essen und ruth
humbel von der cvp erlaubt uns an ein
treffen mit einem lobbyisten mitzukommen
die parlamentarier sind einverstanden
dass wir ihre strategie sie zum filmen
alle ausser der svp und dies trotz
zusicherung dass wir den film erst nach
der schlussabstimmung ausstrahlen
transparenz gefordert dass
kommissionssitze sogar öffentlich
gemacht weiter dass der nötige biss
bauabschnitt wird mit ihr machen sie mit
bei der fdp heißt es ein gesetz zur
massen einwanderungs initiative sei
eigentlich gar nicht machbar
[Musik]
das opfer war einig und svp klar dass
die initiative nicht umsetzbar ist wenn
man da silva
die beziehung kahns gang der ausgaben -
die besteht dass man wenn ich gesagt du
sie weniger als 80.000 einwanderer pro
jahr das will die svp aber letztes jahr
kamen allein über 300.000 grenzgänger
ins land
die initiativen ein zweiter so post
[Musik]
roland ist roland müller direktor des
arbeitgeberverbands
[Musik]
der arbeitgeberverband ist neben economy
swiss der haupt lobbyist in diesem
geschäft in regelmäßigen treffen mit cvp
fdp und svp bringt die wirtschaft ihre
wünsche an herr und frau parlamentarier
ich schieße dazu wir haben dann den
möglichen sieg gestellt
wenn man jetzt die nächsten schritte
gibt erachte mir eigentlich als sinnvoll
dass man schon mal vorlagen blickt also
mehr im vorfeld verschiedene sprach kam
zu fall
eine bürgerliche allianz mit der
wirtschaft solle sein
die fdp will die initiative sanft
umsetzen
keinesfalls die personenfreizügigkeit
mit der eu riskieren
die freisinnigen sprechen von einem
inländer vorrang bei stellenbesetzungen
womit mit dem wirtschaftsverband sie
habe vorrang
sie befürchtet dass das gros sich die
wanderausstellung schrieben
da muss ich ein monat warten bis sie
etwa schon ausstellen dann ist das
riesige bürokratie leicht wirtschaft
lahm oder und damit ob er das wirklich
schon gehört nicht machen und modernem
stand jetzt die wirtschaftsverband wird
in dieser vorschlag unterstützen sie bei
mir würde der prüfungsauftrag mit
finnland reform mittragen will sich nur
wichtig das thema mars flüchten
das ist
direkt ist mit der gewerkschaft habe ich
mit sina rekordzahlung stärkung der
flankierenden massnahmen also mir seid
ihr jetzt die initiative interesse oder
c
und dann war das wenig sie mit der cvp
und svp dass man kein gewitter für ihre
der maßnahme und du wirst im moment am
mittwoch
sie heißt ja noch verlangt beschäftigen
mehr tracht verschärfte kündigungsschutz
die sp steht im abseits eigentlich will
sie die initiative gar nicht umsetzen
und wenn dann sicher nicht gratis sie
will ein gegengeschäft wenn der flug
nicht in länder vorraum dann können wir
sagen wir wollen dafür den steuern da
stehen natürlich verhandlungsmasse
die strategie der sp steuerprivilegien
für reiche ausländer abschaffen den
inländer vorrang der fdp unterstütze man
nur für dieses gegengeschäft
da werden wir kaum durchkommen
sehr erstaunlich
bürgerliche parteien mitziehen haben
sofern das nicht so wirst du auch nur
bleibt bis heute 20 prozent frauen
sitzen bald realität mit der apa die sp
spielt im moment eine nebenrolle
fdp und cvp hoffen einen mittelweg bei
der umsetzung zu finden und die svp
was will die grösste partei wirklich mit
dem bruch mit dem system fasst sich das
krankheitsrisiko homburgers pragmatisch
die mätressen wurde wirtschaft also mit
anderen worten zum schluss völlig
fassungs bestehen mit firmen aus
überhaupt die chance installation man
beste plätze fürchten das kontingent bei
weitere sensation wie ist ein physik sie
jetzt will ich das gespräch ab bevor
sich das geld zuerst nur dank der ote
wird normal so im bewusstsein der seite
das ob sie schon telefon csi krawatte
beschloss und darum was man zuvor
behauptet hatte herr frick sagt dass er
telefoniert hat mit dem härtegrad letzte
woche und vorher liberg also vom herr
blocher prägt sich verlassen kann und
damit eine kontingenz es werden
übernommen
wieder brannte das krupp sieht das heißt
sie wissen dass durch ihr handwerk
suchen portugiese 20 erhöht sondern und
kontingenz und bündelt
aber dann ist der kleber dass man
liefere fdp
das geht aber immer taktik
parlamentarischen sei quasi zum schien
versuchen
kompromiss anbieten aber manchmal
behauptet haben zum einen kompromiss und
die taktische spielweise verbrennen wir
uns halten
funktioniert politik also so viel schein
und taktik
wem kann man da noch trauen und wen
besser nicht
[Musik]
nach der mittagspause geht weiter
alle parteien reichen so genannte
prüfungs anträge ein
das sind vorschläge für das neue gesetz
die parlamentarier stimmen über jeden
antrag ab die vorschläge die angenommen
werden gehen an die bundesverwaltung bis
zur nächsten sitzung werden sie in einem
bericht konkretisiert
[Musik]
das unbestrittene nummer diesen
änderungen abgelehnt wurden doch wieder
höchstzahlen und kontingente rigorose
hatte doch keine höchstzahlen
bekommt den gerne und jetzt um geladene
mitsammeln ordnung
nein
[Musik]
ja aber man muss ja auch man muss die
verwaltung so eine negative sondern
negatives ergebnis gehofft hatte dass
man daraus aber ja sicher
volkswirtschaft damit sind wichtige
vorgabe dass sich johann weg der wahl um
das kommunikative so überspringen sie
rivalen schafft nicht verrückt machen
trainer ich muss wirklich okay
[Musik]
militärischer grad
andreas klärner der neue mann fürs grobe
in der svp-fraktion und zu sichern ist
soll dort ist bewusst ich punkt und der
genannten braucht man nicht mit dem
sorgt meist er weiß damit sind in die
schlagzeilen sicher
[Musik]
mit sophie für mich morgen kommt das
wahlkampfbudget entworfen auf seinem
computer presse und lokalfernsehen
stürzten sich darauf empörten sich
druckfrisch legte sie im büro von
andreas braun sollten sie im ganzen als
walter kommt der besagten so richtig
[Musik]
provokation über alles meine kundschaft
ich halte das für völlig bekloppt die
umfrage wer ist die schönste schönste
hat das rating gemacht auf dem platz
wider willen
cédric wermuth ex präsident der
jungsozialisten mit jungen 25 kam er ins
parlament internet-welt wurde in der 2
die produktions zentraler mittels sieger
fühlen
cédric wermuth das pure gegenteil seines
politischen gegners oder 15 ist zu einem
gewissen grad die unverfrorenheit
insbesondere das fühlt sich natürlich
sehr schon eine sehr wichtig ist ein
warum ausländer die dort präsent die
tube plötzlich ein journalist anspruch
dass man sich zum jahresende das ist
klasse dass ich gegen die widerspruch
aus dem mittelalter die linke ist immer
widerspruch
[Applaus]
das schaulaufen des neuen svp asyl chefs
bei der ortspartei in meilen mit dabei
auch seine freundin und ihr so genannt
meinen daumen heißt es im aufruf mutige
dorf der kantonsgrenze tötens oberwil
lieli die stücke schick meinen die mauer
und den amerikas und meint dass
asylbewerber westendorf netz und haben
nun also hütten wurden bälle bekam
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich stelle fest dass die leute meine
thema medial attraktiv sind nicht die
sind wurden die kommission entscheidend
sind
das parlament dann viele bürgerliche
danke das ist der knaller kommunist nach
mit dem gar mit kompromiss finden
[Musik]
auch zu hause sein kompromisse schwierig
er habe wenig zeit für seine familie
sagt der 30 jährige
versuche einzige hochsee minimum
doch dazu brauche jetzt die wochen zeit
hat sogar aber das clevere vorstellung
nach
um seine rolle im bundeshaus zu finden
habe er vier jahre gebraucht
das müsse bewiesen dass auch das
bürgerschaftsmandat kompromiss so wohl
fühlt sich dann in der titel jedes
morgen die politische parolen paket
gestimmt
[Musik]
und wie ist das beim neu gewählten
parlamentarier glarner deutschland
frankreich und belgien
natürlich lassen sich zum beispiel
muslime schicken unsere agb das gesicht
europas sicher wären dass man sie
angebote entwickelt so souverän punkt
linie familie statistik und nur in der
hand und die an die hand gibt
fortschritte machen aber ich kann aber
die tatsache dass nominieren
politik mit der angst die eigene
identität zu verlieren
[Musik]
arbeiter stimmten mehrheitlich für die
massen einwanderungs initiative cédric
wermuth partei hat keine antwort auf die
kehrseite von multikulti heute beiden
doppelt so viele arbeiter svp sp
so gut die frage wie bringen wir das
nicht in einer ersparnis von rein das
starke medial vermittelte politisiere
wieder lösen muss filme viel direkter
aber wenn ich jetzt nämlich vielleicht
stellt sich vor eineinhalb jahren der
politischen aktion 92 60
[Musik]
die strategie der sp gegen
fremdenfeindlichkeit klassenkampf
am parteitag wollen sie den kapitalismus
überwinden veraltet sagen kritiker
früher welten arbeiter sp um gegen
fabrik chefs zu kämpfen
heute werden viele svw um sich als
schweizer gegenüber fremden abzugrenzen
in dezenten lenkers konzepte wie
schaffst du ein neues bewusstsein für
kollektiv und solidarität zurück zur
alten arbeiterklasse partei aber erneut
lichtkonzepte identität marschieren wir
schon
andreas claras vater auch der gelernte
schreiner war früher mal sozialdemokrat
er ist aber längst aus der partei
ausgetreten ein elitärer haufen
schimpfte heute und er sagt noch ganz
anderes vielfach schenk fast paar wurst
warum nur ein tolles lektüren den
vertrag stand
sie seien sich sehr ähnlich sagt der
vater und andreas glarner ist für einmal
erstaunlich ruhig
was mit ropeter alternativ hat sie
gebraucht haben
das clamer jetzt so und salat mäßigen
gebauten trägt generation armer der
erfolgreiche unternehmer andreas ist
unter ausländern aufgewachsen italiener
und spanien sein vater sagt er habe die
der migrantenkinder geflickt und ihnen
ersatzteile verkauft so habe ihr
kollegen gefunden
hier sehe ich sie sind lohnt sie haben
zur durchführung bekannten zu hilfe
japan erhebt verschwunden
der historische gründe
der eigentliche star zeug legen
[Musik]
ferfried die marke 4 cents kiste juni im
wintergarten größten bußen sorgen und
als margret die macht der familie einen
wunderschönen guten morgen mitgenommen
auch rechte gehört bitte an den
giallorossi aus der wand dass der
branche gerüchte um drogen das kann
morgen schon jetzt
ich freue mich sehr über die
entscheidung er dem druck der eu so
jetzt sehr lange beschäftigen
wir haben uns für die es für den eagles
wird trotzdem jetzt machen wir auf dem
weg nach einer kommissionssitzung
der praxis macht die arbeit unserer
parlamentarier nicht einfacher wird
begrüßen heute morgen es ist ja wirklich
ja wenn wir jetzt auf diese umsetzung
[Musik]
kommen müssen ist es wirklich etwas zu
sagen
die verhandlungen zum neuen gesetz
laufen nämlich nicht nur hier in bern
sondern auch in brüssel mit der eu
er ist unser mann in europa
staatssekretär mario gattiker in der
parlament von bundesrätin sommaruga
das war aber nicht mitlesen und
gattiker versucht seit bald zwei jahren
im auftrag des bundesrats das
freizügigkeitsabkommen mit der eu neu zu
verhandeln
damit die eu eine beschränkung der
zuwanderung akzeptiert bisher ohne
erfolg
die kommen
hat sich der kunde hat dann dossiers
mission possible
das kamera zum schluss des kommunismus
sehr gelungen
die bundeswehr hat behauptete es gäbe
noch chancen für eine lösung aber der
heute morgen konnten wir lesen dass die
720 landes ohne england beschlossen
haben dass der konzentration erregt wie
witz oder nicht
ein mann zwischen zwei fronten
einerseits durch schwierigen
verhandlungen in brüssel
andererseits die dauerkritik der svp an
bundesrat und verwaltung sich die
hauptrunde zu kreuze kriechen
doch ich will eine ganz andere position
vom bundesrat ausprobiert als 30 das
prinzip hoffnung
bezogen auf die verfassungsbestimmung
gefragt hat und das jetzt sollten wir
heute wahrscheinlich überschwemmt mit
jede menge anträgen etwa 25 kommen von
der svp aber stört und respekt auch jede
menge heben
ihr habt meine vorschläge halten die
haben wir mit wissen meinem arbeitgeber
und ökonomisch zusammen erarbeitet
die fdp will noch immer einen vorrang
für inländer auf dem arbeitsmarkt und
auf keinen fall höchst zahlen
sie will keinen ärger mit der eu damit
gerät kurt fluri jetzt aber in einen
clinch
und zwar ausgerechnet mit der cvb
eigentlich die partnerin der fdp gut
hummels kollege gerhard pfister sein
antrag der fdp zu weit bei
wirtschaftlichen problemen wie er
höchstzahlen für zuwanderer
das angekündigt dass ich das ablehnen
werden ausgerechnet jetzt die
bürgerliche mitte bricht auseinander
[Musik]
und was ist mit der sp ihre anträge sind
gescheitert jetzt fehlt sie mit dem
neuen gesetz eigentlich nichts mehr zu
tun haben
es brauche eine neue abstimmung
zu diesem entscheid und entscheiden sich
in die positionen scheinen besonders
setzen könnte oder nein die frage fast
ums änderung oder nicht
viele müller wies dagegen andrea caroni
möchte das wie das bereits aufnehmen
bis jetzt am liebesleben dagegen größer
werden und verfasste mit formellen
abstellen will es zwar geschafft aber
schwächt das kann erhält und dann
verzichtet man sehen wo wir stehen mit
einer kommission gibt es dazu noch bin
ich schon erleuchtungen ja die bemerkung
von petra wünschen nicht erwünscht man
eben zum trost aber immerhin geht so
weiter
[Musik]
er verordnet natürlich irgendwie ist der
gordische knoten zu lösen
das ganze macht es schwierig eine
konkrete abschließend weist der machen
um größeren herrn wenig chancen dass
müssen das verloren
[Musik]
hier hat die svp ihre strategie
definiert wir kennen sie nicht
andreas klan als partei lässt uns nicht
film
außerdem kann sie schon jetzt
nach hause dürfe dokument filmen über
china zu behindern
auftritt der justizministerin
[Musik]
simonetta sommaruga ist hier um den
bericht der bundesverwaltung
vorzustellen
dieser bericht konkretisiert die
gesetzesvorschläge der parlamentarier
zum moor wird sagen grundsätzlich
verstoßen alle vorschläge gegen die
personenfreizügigkeit mit der eu
sogar der sanft der inländer vorrang der
fdp gruppe funktioniere nur wenn die eu
einverstanden sein
was ich bis jetzt seit mitte 2007 die
sogenannten genannte initiative müsste
diese habe ich so weiter gemacht
berichtet dass die eine minute habe ich
die und kontraktion die gut die daumen
ja aber sie hätten wieder geht man muss
deshalb bis ende september auf meiner
position anderen kontexten genau was er
in moskau
nach der botschaft es geht nicht darum
etwas anders aber wenn sie strand machen
nämlich viel zu gefährlich ist
denn land entscheidet immer noch volkmar
verfassung ist und was nicht
bei der cvp ärgert man sich auch dass
die bundesrätin nicht sagt wie stark die
zuwanderung eingeschränkt werden könnte
jede vision und schlossen daraus wurde
beschlossen wir viel weniger könnte dann
theoretisch treue werden geprüft
das ist definitiv
jetzt noch mal sagen mit der kaum raum
darum geht es hier
wie hoch soll die zuwanderung seien von
der regierung kommen keine zahlen
jetzt soll die initianten die svp
klartext reden
die mitte politiker wollen es wissen
wirtschaft seite wegen taxi zu haben die
handlung gegen kritiker vorgegangen
nein mit dem inland fahrer ortschaftsrat
us wirtschaft geben
kurt fluri merkt auch die allianz mit
der svp ist gestorben
die anträge der rechtskonservativen
auffällig der vorschlag von andreas
glarner
er möchte die personenfreizügigkeit am
liebsten ganz abschaffen
damit geht er noch viel weiter als das
stimmvolk entschieden hat
das ist ein widerspruch an zusage von
christoph blocher boxer bilateral war
jetzt halte also ihren handelt müssen
sie doch in dem ntb vorgestellte zum
schluss dass dies jetzt der auftrag mit
christoph blocher
und wenn verbraucher aber öffentlichkeit
besonders seitens zum teil zum spiel
das ist ein spiel
[Musik]
die umsetzung des hochgelobten
volkswillens ein spiel
kurt fluri scheint zunehmend genervt er
ist auch noch stadtpräsident von
solothurn
das heißt 70 stunden waren sie dadurch
aber nicht mehr als bach heute nur noch
der initiative die anzug und der heimat
urlaub bildung
das problem das ich auch politik
[Musik]
klar geworden
sie bedeute keine zeit fand und
kommissionen schafft und nimmt sich zeit
und wie ich das so wie sie war mit auch
stundenlang vor der kommission staub
oder parlamentarier estate um wirklich
politisch zusammen bringt eine springt
lösung findet sich zusammenzuraufen und
len springt nicht ist die ganze massen
von den prozessen kommen und ich habe
gehört dass man nicht das friedenslicht
gemacht und das mit politikerinnen
sitzung nummer 22 lange taten und keine
resultat weit und breit der
gesetzesvorschlag immer noch eine
baustelle
klar ist bisher nur alle anträge der svp
wurden abgelehnt
was für ein konzept hat die partei
andreas glarner sagt nur die zuwanderung
müsse beschränkt werden
ich werde kommen
kurt fluri sagt die svp ne ne bewusst
keine zahlen um nicht darauf behaftet
werden zu können
so können sie jeden kompromiss als zu
schwach ablehnen
aber was ist nun mit den anderen
parteien zeichnet sich irgendeine
allianz ab also stand hält sich
vorstellen als dessen team auch ein
nichts als vage hoffnung
damit verabschieden sich unsere
parlamentarier in die sommerferien
[Musik]
da ist sagt sie
ich grüße meine ferien im engadin total
es ist doch einfach wunderbar
[Musik]
aus wie jetzt in galerien oder sich sehr
früh am strand er unseren stars wie
komme ich mir vor ohne jetzt gehen auch
im kabinett ausgesprochen
[Musik]
das ist wahnsinn natur papiere schwierig
drei generationen humbel machen
orientierungslauf kurz und hummels vater
ihrer tochter und sie selber war früher
sogar schweizer meister in der politik
service.de und da hat sich natürlich im
sport projekt ja das größte
lebensfähigkeit meine dass ich bei jeder
politische thema weiter so
[Musik]
eigentlich ist ruth humbel eine
pionieren als junge studentin brach sie
gleich in zwei männer domänen ein die
des sports und der politik
leicht war es nicht so sichere betanken
unternehmens basiert aber die längste
strecke wissen dass sie mit ihrer mutter
wenn sie so beschäftigt mit der politik
[Gelächter]
natürlich habe sie sich in der politik
darum für externe kinderbetreuung
eingesetzt
also da sich jetzt das wort
frauenrechtlerin aber hört sie gar nicht
gern extrempositionen jetzt liegt mir
einfach so nicht bereit bin
darum bin ich heute wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
seit 13 jahren schon ist die
gesundheitspolitikerin im parlament
dennoch hört man nicht viel von ihr
die politik will das ändern warum willy
gelbe rübe hinderlich man muss sehr
stark bis verstaubtes auch beworben dass
sich eine zuhörerin die partner eine
richtige zicke und ich das ist ein
politisches natürlich die politik zu
machen muss authentisch luther liegt mir
mit solider politik was mir zum beispiel
haben wir noch in höhe macht ist so
schockierend bitte maße zur
wahlinitiative mamacita war es nicht das
ist politik immer noch ärgert mich wenn
man gezogen
[Musik]
ruth humbel die stille ehrgeizigen ihr
stil sei immer noch derselbe wie damals
als sie ins parlament gewählt wurde
anders aber seien heute die reaktionen
aus der bevölkerung
die community auf facebook unterstützen
er gibt mir selber stellen sie sich doch
mal griffen schöner wenn man viel falsch
machen
dafür ist das wissen
ja gut aus es muss sage dir die
persönliche sache so weniger
beschäftigen immer diese sache gelassen
da würde ich mir etwas mehr
wir sind wie inhaltlich oder wenn ich
regulär bis zur marktreife wird und ich
gar nichts aber wieder zum beispiel
verlage und da nicht verlangt
[Musik]
da stehen zwei nachfrage optimal traf du
meinst die variante 5 p
das ist das wo du mit mit dem mit dem
atrix betroffen und die sanktionsfrage
aber dann so richtig verstanden
kurt fluri hat den inländer vorrang
präzisiert und siehe da er entspricht
einer alten forderung der linken
firmen sollen offene stellen den
regionalen arbeitsvermittlungszentren
melden
eine interessante wende ursprünglich
wollten die bürgerlichen einen pakt
schließen nun aber verbinden sich fdp
und spd oder skripten und somit der
minister mit
es ist soweit heute müssen sich unsere
parlamentarier in der kommission auf
einen gesetzesvorschlag einigen unserer
sitzungen
unser grundsatz wie es angehen und das
ist eben noch der spitze nichts was die
sp lehnt die pläne der cvp ab auch wenn
gerhard pfister unterdessen seine
strategie geändert hat von höchst zahlen
spricht er jetzt nicht mehr sondern nur
noch von so genannten abhilfemaßnahmen
aber was für maßnahmen sind gemeint das
lässt feste offen dafür sei der
bundesrat verantwortlich
der dfjp abgestellt war
höchst das ist die schotterpisten
geschrieben einfach aus dem bundesrat
und dem ausgemachten sind wenn ich zu
nennen vor allem wenn der bundesrat auf
höchster ebene
kurt fluri ist alarmiert die cvp will
dass der bundesrat notfalls auch gegen
den willen der eu maßnahmen beschließen
kann einen verstoß gegen das
freizügigkeitsabkommen fz vom 18
[Musik]
das ist doch nicht nur essen
der leader der fdp ist zuversichtlich
dass heute eine kommissionsmehrheit für
seinen inländer vorrang leid stimmen
wird
inzwischen hat nämlich eine geheime
sitzung stattgefunden
kurt fluri hat sich mit der sp und den
kleinen parteien abgesprochen
wir haben die zusicherung erhalten von
der sp der grünen der grünliberalen und
die bdp pensions- heute in der
kommission unterstützen
der haupt
die
[Musik]
so komisch die position wäre findet also
fragen
[Musik]
jetzt gehts ums stimmen zählen 25
mitglieder hat die kommission für die
mehrheit braucht es 13 stimmen
die cvp einheitlich ist und die svp
streng gewesen sein
vorrang muss also die cvp zustimmt dann
käme die sie auf 13
bei der cvp aber stellt sich eine große
frage wie stimmt marian streift die vp
politikerin sitzt in der fraktion der
cvp
sie stimmt aber nicht immer gleich wie
die christdemokraten
ich habe heute morgen noch mit marion
streiff telefoniert sie neigt zu unserem
antrag aber natürlichkeit durch ein
morgen in raestrup dagegen zu sein oder
system etwas abseits aber vielleicht
macht sie mit mit streif hätte die fdp
die mehrheit
aber wenn dir an die hand das konzept
haben sich alle einig sind und ich heute
zweiter feind wurde an den abschlüssen
trete daher fluri zählt seine cousine
siebte stelle sich vor der cvp sind
damit muss man im fluss einfach nur groß
auf dem tisch liegt und wollten das von
er bemüht sich nicht fest
mit denen hat sich noch nie konkret
werden sie war so freundlich ist
konkret hat man gewusst sondern er
wollte alles haben
die rivalität fluri bis zu dürfen
wer ist der beste vertreter von besteht
denn es war ja im grunde müsste
die entscheidende sitzung hinter
verschlossener tür werden nochmals alle
konzepte debattiert
zwei stunden lang stillen
[Musik]
jetzt sehen wir ja gespannt nur schnell
im moment die stadt aus spanien und die
schweiz
die kommission habe sich als release
notes geschieht jetzt die die ganze 16
mit harry potter fan und los sondern ist
gestand mich als postkarte punkt und
eigentlich recht gerne oft gelb
bestrafte group moria zugang
wie würden sie sich dann im saal warten
ihren samstags zustimmen was wir
benötigen ausnahme bestätigt und nach
einer venture mit dem zwar schaffte der
leber mediums an dass er nachher macht
am 11
als ganzes unterstützt hat eine derartig
bootsklasse bekannten ist dass die
kinder die nährlösung social stellen
wenn ich nachmittags oder mit ständiger
gefahr
alle ausser der svp sind also kurt fluri
gefolgt inländer vorrang stadt
höchstzahlen crawford flucht links-grün
fromm und weich wenig heckmotor
koalition bildet und schwyz wochen zu
einer schlechten chancen
ok
befürchtet klarner etwa ein referendum
zu verlieren
von seiner partei jedenfalls wird das
später niemand mehr sagen was man ihr
gar nichts zu tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bedarf
über nacht ein medienstar und alles
wegen dem inländer vorrang leid für die
einen ein held für die anderen ein
landesverräter so viel aufmerksamkeit
zum schluss nie sagen sie mir ich bekam
landesverräter warum wir mit die
initiative umsatzschwach name ist name
ist aber schön dass jetzt sagt anschlag
schlafe und iberia flug eine beleidigung
sie noch keinen die zoologische begriff
luft dort in zusammenhang
veolia und wir machen
juli passiert hauptbahnhofs bahn also
wer also ist dieser flug
er stammt aus einer arbeiterfamilie und
wirkt bescheiden obwohl er als
solothurner stadtpräsident und
nationalrat einer der best bezahlten
politiker der schweiz ist unbescheiden
jedenfalls sein einsatz mehr als vier
stunden schlafe er nie nach der haube
auch die tanz vollkommen zum usus
[Musik]
da gerade
herr fröhlich sie haben fünf stunden
wochen als stadtpräsident ausbau ein
vierteljahrhundert nationalrat sie 13
jahre rekordhalterin parlament mit einem
beamten gesagt das machen dann machen
sie es richtig
wie lange sind sie dem kind brutal
abstimmung so lang aus dass das generell
trage ich kriegen kann gar nicht anders
können und bei deutsche pilot oder stop
ist verdammt wir verfahren entdecken
katze im sack gekauft
nein sie sind die kassen und politik
konnten ist süchtig
sie hat sich gar nicht was wäre wenn ich
nun in der politik wären die wege leiten
der architekt des inländer vorrang slide
zeigt den stapel mails die er von
bürgern bekommen hat also dort zum
beispiel lotto
hallo sie verarschen mich und das ganze
schweiz erfolgt dass wir zu hoffen
erreichen und dann unterschrieben
arno kann
aber wenn das jetzt ja doch der mythos
registriert denn es sind höheres
hatzfeld auf die straße weil mir das amt
wirklich gewaltigen sturm im job
wirklich eine starke identität der
bilateralen gründete er schaffte es der
anstand job und exportindustrie massiv
geschädigt wird bevormundet kurt fluri
das stimmvolk schafft er so nicht den
nährboden für jene die ihr bekämpft
denn sie nicht mit einer äußerst
schwachen umsätzen provozieren doch
genau das verhalten das daneben
radikaler initiative für stimmbürger war
das zeichen setzen und günter fußballs
bornemann setzt jene täter mehrfach auf
das dilemma und mir ist jetzt so gelöst
dass für kommen sagen zur
politikverdrossenheit mitbürger um die
zwei machen was man will sollte lieber
anderen begriff für das mini typisch
glücklich hier zu sein sie denn es
stehen bürger sind gegen eine top
größeren verführen
die sogenannten vereinfacher
die schweizer fünf wochen in rottendorf
und ihr magazin
die svp schlachtet die schwache
umsetzung aus ob sie lust haben
was man so sagen
mit rausch höhere wertigkeit um
gerechtigkeit zu dieser phase des spiel
war somit zentral chile sage ich dem
ausland und der stürmischen saboteur
tschuldigung das zeigt dass dort alle
darin einig von dekra oder sie muss
sagen sturheit mit polemik und apples
anspruch überlegen meint tat der führung
der mannschaft der welt gebracht und
auch andere zu nach landesrat
auf den punkt gebracht die so auf den
punkt gebracht um eine waschechte petra
cvp ethikkommission sah mich als
schauspielerin zu werden geantwortet
dass es die bds kommt der user einfach
reden
also das war oft ausländer das land
und wen sie unter und hier sind
sonderburg voraus bezahlen und irgendwie
aktivieren fokussieren und so und solche
denke ganz viel politik und sie sind
also her bevor wir mal ab ob sie die zur
mit der gesundheitspolitik den anderen
billig zu erwarten mit dem haus stehen
und ich sage dann bin ich überzeugt wird
aufgefordert
das bundeshaus ein haifischbecken
jedenfalls wird hier längst nicht nur
über politische inhalte gestritten
[Musik]
also was mir verwandt ist das heroin
17.000 ich werde das thema ja auch wenn
die normale ist sich mit dem werk
parlaments mitglieder aber der
katastrophe bewusst lügen im netz
verbreiten der machte war dass der urin
solomusiker umgang war es darum gegangen
ist es etwas darum gegangen ist dass man
diesbezüglich verschiedene tätigkeiten
wurde beschnitten wurde siebenter ruhig
der präsident vom sortiment das flugzeug
wie ein getriebe züge von dokument das
risiko von ich bin der sitze gut
schnaubend meiner frau und meinem
zusammen des protokolls mind project
welchen stellvertreter wird er ist ganz
klar vorrang
die beiden 70 schweizer starb als er an
begleitet und die lüge wenn der hut lüge
der jupiter damit ist eine wilde -
zustands juristisch geklauten handwerk
noch möglich gehalten wird
jetzt muss ich und wer würde sagen es
ist aber mehr diskutieren
das volk brot und spiele
was machen sie da
[Musik]
das geschäft kommt in den nationalrat
unsere parlamentarier aus der kommission
setzen nun unter ihren kollegen
wird die mehrheit im saal dem pakt
zwischen der fdp und der sp folgen
ich begrüße bei uns frau bundesrätin
sommaruga und heiße die
kommissionsbericht startete frau amerell
und herrn fluri willkommen herr
präsident die in frau bundesrätin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
selbstverständlich setzt unsere inland
der vorrang leitet die vom volk
akzeptierte initiative nur in geringem
umfang um an der seite haben sich die
initianten nie klar zur konkreten
umsetzung ist das wort für die svp
fraktion hat herr amstutz
hier wird die direkte demokratie
beerdigt
und die das mithelfen dass ein
totengräber bericht weil sie glauben
nicht dass lassen sie die es zu
erledigen
da sind sie zu fein in der fdp sie haben
nichts offensichtlich hände nicht
schmutzig amstutz es gibt verschiedene
fragen von ihren kollegen an sich
dollar fest
erste frage hatte nach kollege amstutz
ist diese anstehende verfassungsbruch
einmalig in der geschichte der
eidgenossenschaft
ja das ist wirklich eine gute freunde
und herr platini
sehen sie die geräte jetzt für
bevölkerung an dem fernsehen was raten
sie den frustrierten stimmbürgerinnen
und stimmbürgern was wurde denn damals
dem schweizer volk versprochen was sagen
sie dazu
kommt mir vor wie er in der cola flasche
ohne poller denn die fdp bringt einen
vorschlag mit ruft die svp macht sich
die live übertragung am fernsehen zu
nutze
15 minuten lang antwortet
fraktionspräsident adrian amstutz auf
rhetorische fragen seiner parteikollegen
so etwas hat es hier noch nie gegeben
eine zwischenfrage ich hatte einige
gelegenheit gehabt versöhnlich
erklärungen abzugeben aber einige roten
sind wie schlicht und einfach zu dumm
dazu es gibt dort unten es gibt dort
unten aus ihren kreisen da stellt man
die ohren am besten auf durchzug
verbuchte mit großer wert
ich verzichte darauf dass sie meine
damen und herren von der svp sich in den
letzten tagen geleistet zu haben als
kindergarten zu verzeichnen was wäre
eine beleidigung für die
kindergärtnerinnen und kindergärtner in
diesem land die wahrheit ist sie haben
kein konzept zumindest keines in der
kommission vor gelöst vorgelegt sie aber
nie interesse an einer lösung gezeigt
sie lügen hier nicht nur das parlament
dann sie lügen die bevölkerung an die am
fernsehen zu schauen
erstens hat die svp schon kurz nach dem
jahr zu massenzuwanderung initiative
konzept festgelegt sie über 50 anträge
eingereicht alles wurde aufgetischt
ich will es nicht künstlich verlängert
haben sie haben mir lüge vorgeworfen das
ist doch ein alter vorwurf ich habe hier
die fahne kennen sie vielleicht wieder
sind die anträge über die wir abstimmen
jede fraktion hat keinen eigenen konzept
antrag gestellt es tut mir sehr leid
einfach dass die menschen am fernsehen
das verstehen
[Musik]
das kommen sie wenn sie wie sie ihr
fußball macht das ist kein stil ich sehe
ist auch welche box macht um sich etwas
vorstellen also ist das show und her
also nein die emotionen sind sie recht
auf eine sich aber in kommissionen nicht
seine darauf dass ich ja schon abschluss
doch was ist das
wäre die frau gespeichert nun hat
erfolgt eine frau ganze hansueli folgt
das juristische gewissen der svp seitens
des parlaments und zweitens des
bundesrates ordnung weiter debatte in
diesem sorge über die personen 30 über
das die masseneinwanderung die
initiative gesagt diese initiative ist
das ende der personenfreizügigkeit jetzt
geschieht etwas erstaunliches folgt
bricht mit einer klaren botschaft seiner
partei
vor der abstimmung sagte die svp steht
das freizügigkeitsabkommen mit der eu
lasse sich neu verhandeln
wie können sie nachdem sich befürworter
und gegner der initiative in einer punkt
im korn waren nämlich dass dies das ende
der personenfreizügigkeit ist wie können
sie einen kommissionsvorschlag
unterbreiten der personenfreizügigkeit
nicht beendet wie so ab und sie dann den
auftrag gegeben dieses fc abzuändern
wenn sie sich einig waren dass es nicht
mehr geld mit annahme der initiative
fluri sagt das stimmvolk wurde getäuscht
mit ihrer initiative habe die svp
versucht die personenfreizügigkeit auf
indirektem weg zu kündigen eigentlich
hätte die partei das stimmvolk fragen
müssen
wollt ihr die bilateralen verträge ja
oder nein
deswegen ist ihre wahre ihre einzige
ehrliche initiative diejenigen die
bilateralen verträge zu können ich hoffe
dir diese initiative erreichen sie
demnach seien dann geht das nämlich auch
um die konkrete frage eine denkwürdige
debatte
sie zeigt auf was passiert wenn
initiativen und internationale abkommen
sich widersprechen
die direkte demokratie kommt an ihre
grenzen
und an der politischen front flammt nun
auch der streit zwischen der fdp und der
cvp neu auf zur allgemeinen überraschung
nämlich wollen gerhard küster und ruth
humbel nochmals über den gleichen
vorschlag abstimmen lassen den sie in
der kommission doch zurückgezogen hatten
der vorschlag der mehrheit ist aber
korrekturbedürftig also muss man das
ändern und offen und ehrlich sagen dass
dem bundesrat die kompetenz gegeben wird
einseitig geeignete abhilfemaßnahmen zu
beschließen ist wenn man zwischen
kommission und parlament und der
kommission ziehen mehr drei jahre nach
ihrer fdp festlegen sikora das papier
für die größte was machen das sehr
bewusst nichts erreicht haben und
stützungsaktionen das natürlich bereue
seine zu fahrrädern aus rheinberg
die ganz ihre stimme verloren stehen das
ganze erst vor gericht auf die sicherung
und stada nicht so eine steuer ist ein
freies land wo ein verletzter recht
zuverlässige dieser position war breit
akzeptierte fraktionen
wer gewinnt der antrag pfister oder der
vorschlag der mehrheit also der inländer
vorrang leid von kurt fluri
sie haben der mehrheit zugestimmt mit 98
zu 93 stimmen bei 5 enthaltungen
kurt fluri sieger des tages
nach einer marathonsitzung von sieben
langen stumpen
wir wünschen ihm
allen einen schönen abend wir sehen uns
heute morgen früh wieder machen
nur dank dem 1
sei es wegen dieses mannes oder nicht
die spd jedenfalls wird die aargauer
parlamentswahlen gewinnen
[Musik]
langenberg
ganz italien auszuschließen
cocktail im audi a8 mindestens note
laufen nicht wieder gelaufen
[Musik]
ja
und während die einen feiern erfahren
wir zum schluss dieses showdowns dass
kurt fluri eigentlich ganz andere sorgen
hat seine frau ist schwer krank
ausgerechnet an diesem nachmittag wurde
sie operiert
[Musik]
und der röslers initiative
alles ist relativ in der politik sowieso
ein halbes jahr ist vergangen
das geschäft muss aber noch die zweite
hürde nehmen
nun ist die kommission des ständerats am
zug
sie baut den inländer vorrang leid aus
die ständeräte wollen mehr auflagen für
arbeitgeber
wer hätte das gedacht die größte
gegnerin der masseneinwanderung
initiative erhält unerwartet auftrieb
den linken geholfen hat ständerat
philipp müller
der freisinnige setzt mehr bürokratie
durch in der hoffnung so die zuwanderung
bremsen zu können
[Musik]
damit geht's in die wintersaison das
geschäft ist nun in der
differenzbereinigung das heißt es geht
hin und her zwischen ständerat und
nationalrat
[Musik]
bis die zwei kammern sich einigen
12 uhr mittag vorbei wieder ein
entscheid des ständerats sofort werden
im keller kopieren der geänderten
gesetzes vorlag gemacht die neueste
vorlage wird an die mitglieder unserer
kommission im nationalrat verteilt zur
erneuten beratung der druck steigt mitte
dezember muss das gesetz beschlossen
seien noch elf tage für unsere
nationalräte heißt dass wieder eine
kommissionssitzung sie beginnt um halb
drei
[Musik]
für abends um sechs war eine
pressekonferenz angesagt erst wird sie
verschoben dann vertrag worüber nur kann
man jetzt noch so lange diskutieren
wer wohnt gibt der sache wo das ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist die kehrseite des glanzvollen
daseins als politiker man kann noch so
lange beraten sich noch so viel mühe
geben alles könnte umsonst gewesen sein
denn die bürgerinnen und bürger werden
nochmals abstimmen
die demokratie ein endloser prozess
die revolution dauert länger im bundes
bern wird weiter gestritten
und langsam liegen die nerven blank
missbrauch vor der ersten partie vor dem
land wenn sie ihr automodell festhalle
genau gespürt und die anderen also meine
da sind so ca
das ist zur nötigen gordischen knoten am
samstag seite die alle medienbruch das
schärfere umsätze jetzt handelt doch
ziemlich oft mit der cvp den vorschlägen
den ortschafts brauchen der e mails
schreibt oder wahrnehmung sagt sie sie
zum ich war da und schwiegen bringt
jetzt so zynisch wie sie so erforscht
sind gesellschaft schutz lange
warteschlange abläuft china abgelöst
da muss ich sie einschnitte porsche
steht der forderung der fdp hat es
erhielten agenda
der strauß theorie also aufbau gemacht
statt nächsten termin nachholen
neuer stoff viel provokateure und
boulevard journalisten
sind geschmackssache
lernen sie die erste
vom 30
es ist absurd
jede hier drin glaubt genau zu wissen
was das stimmvolk wollte und doch sagen
alle etwas anderes
laut kritikern war die initiative unklar
formuliert sie lässt sich
unterschiedlich interpretieren ein
fehler unseres systems sie brachte so
absolutes formuliere dass man näher am
die direkte demokratie muss das
aushalten
alle vorschläge initiativen die als
heikel gelten einzuschränken sind bisher
gescheitert
wer das fordert gilt als totengräber der
demokratie der inländer vorrang leid zum
schluss bleibt ein vorrang für
arbeitslose initiativen die das
parlament für zu radikal hält werden bei
der umsetzung abgeschwächt
herzlichen dank die session ist beendet
das jw lassen
was für ein jahr cédric wermuth der
gezähmte provokateur als verlierer
gestartet jetzt sieger in dieser arena
wir werden muss man muss man etwas ist
wahnsinnig ich glaube ich habe mit
seiner mitarbeiter auch einen unter
beweis stellen für die hinterste und
letzte dass ich bereit bin an tiroler
von parlamentariern spieler bringt die
das jetzt für die künftige politische
karriere bisher nur junge frau ist
nämlich ist das einfach sprach von
ungewöhnlichen
andreas klärner vordergründig der
verlierer aber seine partei hat es
geschafft die schweiz drei jahre lang
mit diesem thema auf trab zu halten
so war zu hören dass wir einige maus auf
die spur sie dann nicht einmal wo
[Musik]
kurt fluri er hat den grundstein gelegt
für das jetzt verabschiedete gesetz
praktisch und im film medienkontakt und
das ist ja interessant und jederfrau
gewässer also wir uns ist sondern ich
habe am start erwartet beginn der
heim-wm schön und gut
[Musik]
die selber kaputt
die cvp politikerin und ihre partei sind
die wahren verlierer in diesem geschäft
aber hat man das überhaupt mitbekommen
also ich möchte mit svp die plastination
aktuelles ich weiß nur dass sie nicht
umgesetzt ist ein schwachpunkt vor das
einen schwachen start re aber
schließlich schwach dass du im beruf da
hatten wir schon so in haslach das sich
seit jahren politik recht kompliziert
wir haben die botschaft
also ich habe es auch entspricht
vorwärts und wieder zurück ratzmann
sowie zwei weitere büros sind verletzt
unsere direkte demokratie ein langer
zermürbender prozess vielleicht nicht
perfekt aber sie ist das was die schweiz
ausmacht
[Musik]
die fahren
weil die bric-staaten dennis crowley ich
bin freudig die eindhoven
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du hast du hast sie aufgenommen
[Musik]